okay so it is truly an immense pleasure
for me to introduce Phil sharp to you
today let me first tell you a few facts
about Phil he was an undergraduate at
Union College in Kentucky he earned his
PhD in chemistry from the University of
Illinois and he then went to Caltech to
do postdoctoral work with norm Davidson
at the time that electron microscopy was
first being used to the same in the
structure of DNA molecules thereafter he
went to Cold Spring Harbor lab where he
was a staff member for several years and
in 1974 he went to MIT where he
continues to be so it was at MIT that he
and his co-workers did the extremely
elegant our loop mapping analyses that
uncovered the existence of introns in
adenovirus pre-messenger rnas and as you
know those insights led to the Nobel
Prize in 1993 so there are a couple of
things that I had have always admired
very very much about Phil first is the
creativity and the foresight that
characterizes his science he has
invariably been on the cutting edge the
forefront of every new and exciting
discovery in the field of gene
expression for instance after the
discovery of introns his lab identified
the lariat structure that characterizes
pre-mrna intermediates in the splicing
reaction very very beautiful mechanistic
work on splicing concurrently his lab
was doing a lot of the basic work on
understanding transcription initiation
and its regulation in mammalian cells
including characterizing what a lot of
the basal transcription factors do a
little bit later many of the initial
discoveries that have now led to a
molecular understanding of alternative
splicing came to his lab and of course
all these things not only
contributed to our understanding how
cells work in general but also very
specifically to an understanding of
viruses and cancer and most recently his
lab has been seminal in doing
experiments that lead to an
understanding of micro RNA function and
I'm hoping I expect that there's a good
chance that he'll be talking about the
next new frontier in his talk second
many of the current leaders in the field
of gene expression and RNA have been
trained by Phil among them are Jim manly
Tom - Sheila Bob Kingston's Deibert
hausky Melissa Moore Band Plinko
filsaime R and many others so this is
quite an impressive list the impact is
wide reaching the third reason I admire
Phil is that he has been an incredible
citizen of science he served on in many
advisory capacities and on many
committees that have shaped the future
direction of science and this even
includes neuroscience as I think some of
you might have guessed from the
questions he was asking this morning
moreover he's been instrumental in
putting novel scientific findings to
practical use so he was one of the
scientific founders of Biogen and more
recently of an island pharmaceuticals
which has been successfully developing
therapeutics based on RNA interference
so Phil we are very much looking forward
to your talk
Thank You Joan it's a real honor to be
invited to participate in this program
particularly in view of the outstanding
talks we heard this morning and the
outstanding speakers I also need to
thank or congratulate Yale on Medical
School on its two hand 200th anniversary
we're selling a celebrating an
anniversary at MIT this year it is our
hundred and fiftieth so we're the new
kids on the block and it's nice to come
to what are the older institutions to
learn something about science and
particularly biological science which is
so extraordinary developed here and it's
also an honor to have Joan Stites
introduce me Joan has been a remarkable
leader in the field and citizen and it's
always an honor to share a meeting or a
an event with Joan I'm going to talk
about the roles of RNA in gene
regulation but I'm not even going to try
to cover that topic I'm going to talk
about a couple of issues that are
emerging that I find interesting an
interesting view and I'm going to stress
some of the newer insights that we've
been thinking about but let's speak
generally initially about the role of
RNA in gene regulation
I think this well this field is
beginning to explode it's exploding for
a very simple reason we now have a new
set of tools to do deep RNA sequencing
and to be able to then characterize at
the level of less than one RNA per cell
the nature of gene regulation and gene
expression in specific cells and this is
going to lead us to a whole host of new
insights as to the roles of RNA in the
regulation of cells that we have not
been able to study and see before and
it's going to profoundly change how we
understand cell biology now an example
of this was the discovery of RNA I in
1998 by far and mellow and that opened
the whole field of RNA interference and
the understanding that RNA can be a
regulatory model molecule a very common
regulatory molecule in biological
systems and we know now that RNA is
keyed on double strand RNA as a key
signature for the initiation of these
processes that if within cells silences
genes at a post transcriptional level by
cleavage a message related processes
silenced genes at translation and
related processes silenced genes a
transcriptional stages and this is
particularly evident in PI RNA and
controlling transpose ax balelo's
but I suspect that there are many other
layers of regulation that will engage
RNA in transcriptional control that were
just beginning to see the first hints of
in our analysis of RNA populations but
over the last 10 years this field has
advanced enormous li and just a glimpse
at one of the things that has emerged
from the field is the ability to use RNA
to actually silence any gene in
mammalian cells or in most other
organisms as well and this is the
ability to introduce a small interfering
RNA that has the sequence complementary
to a DNA gene and therefore neutralize
the expression of messenger RNA from
that gene in a Cell this gives us my
first designs the ability to focus the
inactivation of a gene and ask what is
the biological function of that gene and
this has fundamentally changed how we do
cell biology and how we can advance the
field and it's remarkable in its effect
but if you think about it that most
diseases are the products of specific
genes we treat diseases by inhibiting
the activity of specific genes we do
that by making small molecules to
enzymatic activities within the cell are
making larger molecules or small
molecules to
actors on the surface of the cell and if
you can actually treat specific genes by
si RNA to silence them we can have many
of the same effects by a process in
which you use RNA to silence a gene in a
diseased state and this has led us to
begin to develop and I will not discuss
it further the abilities to introduce
RNA within cells in in human body and
and in model organisms and probe the
activity of genes and treat diseases
potentially in in patients and this is
undergoing development and I suspect and
anticipate that in the emerging years in
front of us
we will have a general approach to a new
pharmaceutical activity through
components such as RNA introduced into
cells however the most common impact of
the regulation of genes by RNA that we
know about today is through the activity
of micro RNAs
these are RNAs that are encoded by the
genome and are transcribed from our
genome into hairpin RNAs that are then
processed by Jascha an activity in the
nucleus and transported to the cytoplasm
where a Dicer activity here leads to the
cleavage of the RNA precursor to an SI
RNA structure entering and Argonaut
complex now half of all the genes and
our cells are regulated by these small
RNAs typically by pairing and silencing
through the activity of this RNA leading
to translational inhibition and in many
cases degradation of the message
occasionally these RNAs that are coded
by our genome as micro RNAs can silenced
as well by complete complementarity and
in that case Argonaut it Cleaves a
message or RNA so we now know that at
least half of all the RNAs that are
expressed in ourselves as messenger
rna's half of all our genes are under
control of small RNA system expressed in
each of our cells differing between
cells that control the
of those messenger rna's now the
specificity for that control was
originally described by Ambrose and
Ruffman in their initial discovery of
Lin for as a regulatory RNA for the
activity of lin-14
and they identified by mutation that
these sequences near the 5 prime end of
the messenger RNA were the specificity
for pairing to this messenger RNA and
reducing its level of translation and
david bar-tailed using bioinformatics
analysis generalize this model and
identified these positions between 2 & 8
as the key positions called the seed
region for the specificity of the
pairing between these small rnas and
messenger rna's leading to their
regulation so what do we know about the
extent and the nature of this type of
regulation in mammalian cells now we
know that most of the target sites for
regulation by micro RNA are these seed
interactions in the three prime UTR that
untranslated region at the end of the
message there are some target sites
within the reading frame of the message
where it encodes protein but those are
much rarer than those specifying the 3
prime in there is some evidence less
than 1% of all the interactions of micro
rnas or through this type of Center
paired activity but most of it 99%
appears to be through this type of
activity most protein silencing due to
micro RNA regulation is about 1.5 fold
to 2 fo it is a very tuning type of
regulation and we'll come back to that
later
with one example of data but if you have
multiple target sites between a
messenger RNA and a micro RNA you can
get extensive regulation much greater
than tenfold as I mentioned before most
of the regulation is through RNA
degradation but some of it is also
through translation and this is a field
that is very unclear now and that is the
question as to how
much engagement there is between micro
RNA and transcriptional activities in
the nucleus of a cell it is clear micro
rna's can enter the nucleus and have
pairing the messenger RNA our precursor
the message but does say they have more
extensive regulation at the level of
gene expression but we know these RNAs
play a critical role both in normal
processes and you'll hear about that
later I'm sure
from David Baltimore and others but they
also have important roles in disease
processes and us briefly discuss how
micro RNAs are thought to interact and
engage the process of development of
cancer as you well know from the work of
many in the field and this is from an
example of Weinberg and Hanahan and 2000
there are multiple pathways that when
deregulated lead to changes in gene
expression cell proliferation cell death
that are critical for the development of
cancer we now know from sequencing the
human genome that there are tens to
hundreds of mutations in most individual
cancer cells at every cancer cell differ
somewhat from other cancers due to these
mutations and as you might expect micro
RNAs are also critical parts of the
pathways that control the development
and the regulation of cancer these micro
rna's suppress pathways such as rasp
which burns slack here initially
identified as extensive studied which
controls changes in gene expression and
cell proliferation there are micro rna's
that control cell death micro RNA is a
controlled proliferation and signaling
through other pathways that we know by
mutation are absolutely critical for the
activity of a cancer cell to become
fully malignant and spread we see these
micro RNAs acting in the two modes that
we know protein coding genes also act in
development of cancer they can be
drivers of cancer as oncogenes NF
kappa-b amplification NF kappa-b dry
micro RNA 155 that promotes the growth
the cell's amplification of 1792 is
known in many human cancers promoting
the activity of cell growth and
suppressing cell death and micro RNA 121
il-6 stimulates and contributes to other
cancers but the most common theme in
micro RNA regulation in cancer is the
loss of activity in the cancer process
and this is illustrated here on this set
in which a number of micro RNA is listed
here which are known to either be down
regulated or lost in some cancers that
contribute to prostate lung other types
of cancer
they control cell death cell growth
other signaling activities DNA
methylation translational activities as
well so the general theme that one sees
from looking at cancer cells is loss of
activity is a contributor to the
development of malignancy so the
question arises then can a decrease in
the regulation by a micro RNA which is
frequently observed in cancer can this
promote malignancy and I want to briefly
introduce the work of an our Kumar
graduate student Tyler Jack's at MIT
who've used a mouse model to study this
process and what they did was to take a
mouse model of lung cancer or a sarcoma
here this is the induction of sarcoma in
a mouse model in which they have under
conditional expression grass which when
activated will promote cancer and found
it about 80% of minicamp of cancers p53
when flux out will delete p53 p53
protects us against cancer by monitoring
the integrity of the genome and Dicer
the activity I mentioned before that is
critical for the acts expression of
micro Hornets
so if vizor is deleted in a cell you
would expect the cell would lose all
micro rna's lose regulation of a major
portion of its activities at the level
of
cytoplasmic control and what they
determined is and asked the question
here is how significant is loss of micro
RNA in the development of cancer in this
sarcoma model so here is the black line
this is numbers of days this is survival
of animals we're talking about 18 mice
here and what you see is that if you
have wall type Dicer you get full micro
RNA activity and you get cancer in a in
these animals about 200 days now if you
take one allele of Dicer making it a
heck low allele delete it out of
induction of this flocks activity you
get cancer then in about a hundred days
a two-fold acceleration and the rate of
cancer if you take both alleles under
Dicer you actually delay the development
of cancer and all the cells that come
out of this animal when typed for Dicer
are heterozygous one deleted Dicer
allele one Dicer present only so what
this tells you is that a decrease by
deletion of one allele of Dicer
accelerates the rate of cancer loss of
micro activity you can characterize the
level of micro RNA activity it is
reduced approximately two fold but if
you ask in this in Deebo setting for a
cancer to develop in the absence of
micro RNA you do not get cancers
emerging from that model now if you look
across as man who kumar did human
sequencing data and asked how common is
it in human tumors to see a mutation in
one allele of the Dicer gene what you
observe is through a large number of
different types of cancer a significant
fraction of the Dicer at genes in those
tumors is a hemizygous loss so that
means one allele is lost the other
alleles retain micro RNA loss in
activity is correlating with the
development of cancer in these models so
loss
micro RNA controls seems to relax the
regulation system in these tumors to
promote the growth and survival of cells
in an Indy vole model but you do not see
in this model and in the
characterization of these tumors the
total loss of Dicer activity and the
total loss of micro RNA regulation so
that leads to a question as our micro
RNA is essential for cancer our central
for cell growth of somatic cells in
vertebrates and if you ask that question
which we did by taking these Mouse
sarcoma cell lines from Kumar and Tyler
and the leading the other allele of
Dicer and creating cell lines that are
totally devoid of wild-type Dicer
activity now when we do this by inducing
the deletion of Dicer half of all the
cells that come out of this grow quite
nicely so we're not selecting for a
subset of cells and once you observe the
cell lines that grow for years at a time
that have no micro RNA regulation at all
so first lesson is that micro RNA is not
essential for the viability of somatic
cells as it is not essential for the
viability of embryonic stem cells which
was shown for a number of years ago if
you actually look at the micro RNA
population in those die sir deleted cell
lines that's along this axis here note
this is a logarithmic scale along this
axis is reads from cloning a small RNAs
out of a parental Hemis hello dice or a
cell line what you see is a to log
decrease in all the micro RNAs that are
expressed in those sarcoma cell lines so
you get a 2 log decrease this is not in
micro RNA it was misidentified it's a
snow RNA you get a 2 log decrease in all
the micro RNAs in the dice or deletion
cells though these cells grow quite
nicely and have a flipper T rate
slightly slower
than the Dicer plus aliens so the first
thing all this micro RNA regulation is
not essential for cell growth in cells
and culture now you can ask the question
while is it essential for the
development of tumors in a certain
challenge model in this case and this is
one of several experiments we've
subcutaneously injected 25,000 cells of
those Dicer deletion types into a new
drug - Mouse and waited for the
development of cancer if you have dye
surplus with micro rna's you see tumors
in about 21 days that continue to
develop over 46 but in the Dicer - by 46
days slightly slower you actually see
the development of tumors you recover
the tumors they have the same pathology
as those with micro RNAs and therefore
and you can clone cell lines back out of
this and show that they do not have
micro rhynocs they have not recovered
micro RNA regulation so what that tells
us is that you can actually see a cell
develop tumors in a challenge by
subcutaneously infection but you do not
see tumors develop if you actually ask
for the development de novo of a Dicer
deletion micro RNA negative cell in vivo
now the answer and the difference
between those two settings is probably
in the early stages of tumor development
in vivo where hypoxia and other stress
stresses the activated cell in ways that
it has to then deal with to become a
viable tumor and the reason I argue this
is that in every case in which we have
derived cell lines that are dalat
deleted in Dicer we've done it in
multiple examples those cells turn out
to be remarkably sensitive to stress so
in this case in that Mouse sarcoma cell
system here is the cells of expressing
activated caspase oxidative stress you
see large amounts of
cell death here's a mouse embryonic stem
cell deleted advisor genotoxic stress
you get massive induction of cell death
whereas those cells with micro rna's do
not induce significant cell death
telling you that micro rna's are
important for dealing with stress in
many settings probably in the early
stages of development of tumors that
micro rna's are not required for the
growth of cells or the growth of cells
even in a tumor state when you inject a
significant number of cells so i won't
go through this but i can show you if
time that in embryonic stem cells the
pathways that induce cell death and
arrest cell cycle or many of them are
under control of p53 and the predominant
set of micro rna's and embryonic stem
cells have been shown by us and many
others to suppress the activity of cell
death genes and genes that are required
for a rest of cell cycle under DNA
damage and therefore loss of these micro
rna's would explain why these cells are
sensitive to stress so if micro rna's
are not required as a regulatory system
in general for viability of cells and
you can develop tumors without micro RNA
regulation though we know micro RNA
regulation is critical and can drive in
certain settings the developments of
tumors how do we visualize micro RNA
regulation and I think it's best
visualized in the generality not in the
specifics as providing a robustness to
biological systems our robustness that
stabilizes cells in cell states such as
quiescent studies and micro RNAs that 7
is an important part of an example of
that suppressing grasp it stabilizes
differentiation by suppressing genes
that are expressed in other cells and
therefore maintain cells in
differentiated States and maintains help
cells make transitions between
graduated states and as I ate it it
allows the cells to respond to changes
in the environment such as DNA damage
and other activities that otherwise
would not be controlled adequately not
to induce cell death let me show you an
example of just how a micro RNA set
confers or doesn't confer the
differentiated cell state and in this
example we've taken a cell this is the
vesicle stem cell which is a cell line
that has been isolated by introduction
of a large t antigen it's a gene that
allows the cells to undergo
immortalization and we've done a
microarray analysis on the genes
expressed and there's thousands of genes
here expressed in this Meza Cardinal
stem cell and I'm comparing here the
changes in that gene expression between
that cell having Dicer two alleles of
Dicer it's a wild type and those knocked
out totally devoid of micro RNA
regulation so if you go from micro RNA
regulation to non micro RNA regulation
you see very little change same thing is
true here of embryonic stem cells
wild-type
Dicer plus with micro rna's delete the
micro RNA is very little change less
than 2% of all genes change and most of
that change is less than 1.5 fold even
that 2% but if you go from that
embryonic stem cells to mesenchymal stem
cells you get a dramatic change in gene
expression so this is the difference
between micro RNA regulation and this is
the difference between cell type
regulation so micro RNA regulation
contributes even when you delete all of
it a small amount to the difference
between different cell types but it can
be an important component in many sense
so I conclude is that microRNAs can
control the properties of cancer cells
but are not essential for cell viability
and not even essential for the growth of
cancer type cells in that animal micro
rna's confer or bust nest
Seiler transitions and states and micro
rna's contribute a small fraction of
regulation in stable cellular states but
they're absolutely central for many of
the transitions between different cell
states during differentiation and during
the induction of stress like type
activities so they provide a buffer
against changes in gene expression of
transcriptional and other levels in that
type of transition let me spend the rest
of my time talking about a another view
of RNA in gene regulation that I find
fascinating and can relate to and common
interest between Joan and myself and
that is this issue here
widespread transcription of genomes and
it has been reported here in many other
places that if you look in mammalian
cells in vivo and in vitro you can find
low levels of transcription of most of
the genome even though only 2% of it
encodes messenger RNA and about 10 to
15% encodes the priests precursors to
that message what is all this
transcription about and we've been we
know that there's transcription of genes
that don't encode message non-coding
RNAs they've been identified by
chromatin modifications and arguments
about conservation excess hot air and
others have been studied a few of them
but they do not come close to accounting
for this general transcription what
we've been looking at over the last
several years is a low abundance of
non-coding rnas associated with
promoters and enhancers and I'd like to
give you some comments on that because I
think it leads to an interesting idea
that may even be true
so if we look at transcription this is
the model in which we understand
transcriptional regulation now where you
form a complex with polymerase at
promoter sites you get escaped from the
promoter the polymerase elongates over a
short distance it pauses after it causes
there's the activity of PTF B from the
pause site releasing the polymerase for
further elongation and you get
elongation across the G so pausing is a
very common characteristic of expression
of genes most promoters in many cells 70
80 percent of them have preliminaries
paused at the promoter site and release
from pausing is a significant point in
regulation but we were interested in
this process when we did deep RNA
sequencing of small RNAs out of an
embryonic stem cell and what we found by
sequencing RNAs that were 18 to 30
nucleotides at a depth of 10 to 20 30
million 40 million RNA spur preparation
is that what we found were small RNAs on
a meta gene plot that would correlate
with the site of initiation of
transcription the transcriptional start
site for the sense gene which would then
be in this direction and is coded here
in red but we also saw a set of RNAs
that come from the transcriptional start
site peeking ups dams upstream and
negative direction about 250 nucleotides
and we have no idea what this was about
this we could expect from pause
polymerase giving you small RNAs this we
did not expect as an antisense
transcript and we saw this for the vast
majority of the promoters in these cells
when we started comparing that data to
other data from rick young and other
labs who have done polymerase
localization experiments where they've
used an antibody to chip out polymerase
2 in these cells after fixing it
the DNA and doing forward and reverse
reads what you observe is that there's a
polymerase paused in the Cinch direction
and that's that peak there and it
generates two Peaks but there's a second
polymerase upstream we know
transcription modifies the chromatin by
h3k4 methylation you CH cream
methylation in the Cinch direction this
peak but you also see it in this peak so
polymerase is there as well as
modifications of chromatin so 70% of all
transcriptional start site exhibit what
we call divergent transcription -
polymerase is going in the opposite
direction
these are enriched in CPG Island
transcription start sites and Pauls
polymerizing and chromatin modifications
confirm the polymerase is there in
generating these small RNAs or could be
generating these small RNAs so we've
gone on to characterize that antisense
transcript from a subset of genes
because I wanted to know in detail what
was the nature of the process going on
in the antisense direction so what we've
learned and I'll briefly summarize that
and tell you where I think it will take
us so here's a gene I'll use it as an
example but we've done this for several
others here's the polymerase Peaks on
that gene and you see a sense polymerase
this is the sense transcript here the
polymerase has paused above it here is a
chromatin modification consistent with
the elongation of the polymerase here's
where we found the antisense RNA is
short RNAs and when we characterize the
RNAs coming from this region by very
sensitive five primaries and three
primaries we find these small RNAs are
downstream of Capps sites of initiation
of the polymerase and the RNAs can
extend several thousand nucleotides in
the antisense direction there's a family
of different links not in a unique
length spanning from 50 out to a
thousand
so these polymerase is undergoing
elongation summary of that is that the
any sense rnase are capped the antisense
RNA is range from 50 to thousands of
nucleotides and the steady state level
of these any sent transcripts is 1 to 4
copies per cell
I will recall for you that there's only
2 copies of DNA per cell so there is if
these are nascent rnase there's RNA with
the polymerase engaged in both of those
anti sense directions on both copies of
that gene now the X question is well is
it paused and this is the anti sense
transcript under the same regulation by
PT FB as the one in the sense direction
and here is an easy way to test that we
as I mentioned before Paul's site escape
is mediated by P 2 FD it is due to
negative regulatory factors net and D
SIF and PTFE is a kinase phosphorylates
all three polymerase and these two
activities releasing the polymerase for
elongation but we've known for many
years that there's a set of small
molecules drugs that inhibit this kinase
activity called flavo Piron all and a
number of others and the question was do
you see inhibition of the antisense
transcript if you inhibit the PTFE
activity and here's an example of that
for four different genes note here this
is a 60 minute treatment this is spliced
RNA nascent RNA and upstream antisense
RNA this is the antisense transcript
this is the nascent sense transcript
this is a spliced RNA in the cytoplasm
and with inhibition need to see no
change in the spliced RNA levels
normalized to one which is consistent
with a 60 minute inhibition it's a very
stable population however nascent RNA in
the sense Direction very sensitive to
Flavel paranal drops to about 5% within
60 minutes antisense RNA from all four
genes drops five or more fold within 60
minutes saying that that polymer is
going in the antisense direction is
actually dynamic it is depending on PT
FB for its elongation if you inhibit it
it goes away within 60 minutes you can
look at the kinetics this is again the
antisense transcript versus the nascent
RNA and here you see a decrease over 60
minutes one minute inhibition 30 and 60
wash it out it comes right back within
30 minutes so these RNAs appear back in
the cell the polymerase in the antisense
directions engaged in making RNA in the
sense direction you see the same
activities so that tells us in this
divergent transcription that the
antisense transcription is the long
Gatien of any sense RNAs require the
activity of PT FB and the CD k9 kinase a
synthesis of the antisense is dynamic
has a half-life sharply slightly longer
than that of the nascent RNA in the
sense direction and I would didn't show
you the evidence but exosome which is
nuclease known to control RNAs that are
in the nucleus of the cell it targets
the antisense transcript for degradation
at least in part there might be other
decorated pathways so this gives us a
picture of transcription not only in
embryonic stem cells but I should say in
other cells as as John lists showed it
with us initially in a parallel
publication and by many others in other
cell types that many promoters in the
majority of promoters in some cells have
a since polymerase going in the sense
direction and in any sense polymerase
going in the antisense direction both
under control of activities to the
initiation complex and elongation beyond
PTFE giving you to polymerization
sensitive urgently transcribed now I
won't show you the data it's actually
being developed now but in cells there
are 20,000 enhancer type sequences these
are DNA sequences recognized by
transcription factors that drive the
transcription of genes that are nearby
and I can
sure you that a large fraction of the
enhancers in embryonic stem cells and in
neuronal cells have divergent RNA coming
from them as well
polymerase is generating RNA in both
directions this was first recognized by
Greenberg in the neuronal system of
false activation and false enhancers a
paper in science a year ago and now
we've looked at in embryonic stem cells
and the evidence is pretty clear that is
also driving RNA transcription in both
directions so we have now a large number
of sites in cells from promoter sites
and from enhancer sites in which you get
the Virgin transcription so what role
could it have the it could facilitate
nucleosomes free Regent's polymerases
are little motors that move in two
directions so they can expose DNA
sequences
it can provide signals in the form of
nascent RNA to target RNA binding
proteins to promoters and enhancers and
it can provide a platform for looping
type interactions through these types of
proteins or other activities between
promoters and enhancers that are well
described in the nucleus of mammalian
cells but what explains the instability
of the antisense transcript why if these
RNA polymerases are undergoing
transcription through DNA sequences with
caps and other activities why are they
terminating and what accounts for the
low abundance and instability of the
RNAs from those anti-sense transcripts
and from enhancer driven RNAs and I
think the answer to that is going to get
play into an emerging theme in our
understanding of gene expression in
cells and then the last few moments let
me explain what I'm thinking here and
they anti-sense transcripts and the
enhancer transcripts are probably
unstable because they do not have the
coupling of transcription and splicing
and that signaling between
transcription and splicing accounts for
productive transcription in the sense
direction and the lack of it in the
antisense direction so there's several
recent papers that illustrate the
coupling of transcription elongation
with splicing gene begs in a very nice
paper showed that splicing dependent RNA
polymerase causes in yeast where there
are splicing signals within genes
showing a communication between splicing
signals and polymerase elongation Gideon
Dreyfus reported in a very nice paper
that u1 which is a component of splicing
complex promotes precursor RNA from
premature cleavage I'll illustrate that
in a moment in polyadenylation and
blanco and others reported that splicing
and chromatin modifications are in
communication with one another
throughout the body of the gene let's
take an example here of Gideon dreyfuses
insights what he showed in the
expression of genes in mammalian cells
is that within the sequences of the gene
there are these sequences that could be
read as polyadenylation signals if you
one is recognizing through RNA sequence
complementarity the precursor RNA it
suppresses this Polident elation
reaction within a gene allowing the
polymerase to elongate without you one
you get cleavage and termination so in
the absence of u1 for example the
polymerase would proceed here make this
cleavage would occur you get an RNA with
poly a on it and you get termination of
elongation this would be degraded so
this shows that elongation by polymerase
is coupled to splicing recognition now
that's a much more extensive model in
that if you've synthesized what's
available in the literature so what
looks like is happening is there's an
extensive coupling of transcription and
RNA splicing throughout the body of
genes that are expressed and making
sense messenger
ranae's and this is I won't take you
through this in detail but this is the
way I would conceptualize it and others
have conceptualized it in which there is
a transcriptional start site where
polymerase initiates you get
communication between PTFE is a kinase
which phosphorylates these factors also
facilitate is facilitated by recognition
of chromatin the polymerase moves away
PTFE at specific factors many others u1
and u2 begin to interact they are
associated with activities that are
recognizing chromatin modifications h3k4
trimethylation has been shown here fact
a nucleus on opening factor and then the
complete spliceosome forms giving you
productive transcription and coupling to
splicing in this coupling between
splicing transcription and activities
allow the polymerase to elongate
throughout the body of the gene and i
would propose that in the antisense
direction this communication is probably
not there so that leads to the last
conjecture and that is the coupling of
elongation splicing and polyadenylation
signaling suggests that only genomic
regions encoding sets of RNA processing
signal sequences would be transcribed
efficiently in the rapidly processed RNA
as mrna after splicing transported to
the cytoplasm introns are degraded and
perhaps and this is totally conjecture
now perhaps RNAs transcribed from other
regions such as the antisense and from
enhancers generate signals do through
their daggered ad pathway that can be
read back to the chromatin to indicate
that these do not encode sent signals
button code sequences that don't have
the coordinated recognition for splicing
and therefore silenced the chromatin
activity if that's true it gives us a
way of integrating the information
necessary for the expression of genes
into the transcriptional expression
process and I would not be surprised if
that the
not turn out to be correct so what I've
tried to give you is an overview of
regulation by RNAs focusing on micro
RNAs as the most common example and
showing that this is a very extensive
system that doesn't that confers at
least in stable cell types of robustness
to the cell and give you some picture of
what I suspect is the emerging I
relationship between the coupling of
gene expression gene structure and
elongation by polymerase thank you